all right let's talk about toilets the
French are gonna be putting toilets in
their kitchens yeah that's right we've
got a little more info for you so there
you just change this law in France
previously the law had required the
toilets were not directly accessible
from living rooms or kitchens all right
the change to the building code does
away with the prohibition of direct
communication between the closets and
kitchens and living rooms
this will allow contractors to build new
toilets in living accommodations all
right I'm not French so I don't know
exactly what's going on here so first
off if you're French please let me know
right down below I personally would not
want a toilet in the kitchen
no it's why why is it because the
population there's too many people there
having to build smaller hey you put it
all in one room so I do think there is
some element to that that literally the
apartments are getting smaller and
people are looking I lived in New York
City in a tiny apartment where you know
I could basically reach my stove and
poop and you know reach out the window
at the same time so yeah but it's not we
don't want this nobody wants living
really it's where I'm most comfortable
and where I can have a snack and just
relax and matter eat some light reading
yeah that's also where I'm pooping Allah
a lot of people with TVs in their
bathrooms I'm fine with that yeah and
like when I want to go to a hotel and
I'm like there's a TV you are never
leaving right what is that there a
distinction between the toilet in the
living room which if you're watching a
basketball game you don't want to get up
but you know we've all seen those like
lazy boys that faked it like you got it
you could take a dump and watch the game
okay but that there's some sort of
sanitary difference between taking a
dump in the living room which I suppose
you can rationalize and taking a dump in
the kitchen like all right I'll give you
a [ __ ] all right fine that's fine yes
the best kitchen to party I will
it would seem far people of lists I want
a top ten places that you'd like to [ __ ]
in your house god that's so amazing like
a nice poop on the lanai alright so the
last point on this whole silly topic is
is the West going backwards in a weird
way like because of population and we're
packing all these people in to these
small places but now we have to have
toilets in kitchens like that's
something that maybe they had when they
had when you had to cram all these
people into a place wait you know
hundreds of years ago or a hundred years
ago I'd say and now we're sort of going
back so is the West slipping up here I
think not only are they slipping up but
with we're gonna double what go to ten
billion people by 2050 not only are they
gonna put toilets next to refrigerators
but they're gonna have to find a way to
make it fancy so they're gonna I predict
they're gonna start featuring this in
Better Homes and Gardens and in Vanity
Fair and make it a super fancy
experience because we're not gonna have
to have we're not gonna have a choice
yeah the West our days done I'm just
picturing all the times when I like was
supposed to cook something and I put
something in the pan that I was not
supposed to put in there
and like if you add poop and pee to that
whole list of things at the ready it's
just gonna be a bad experience so yes
the end of West I think we go back to
Bret for a second because your posture
implies that you could because when
you've taken poop you're supposed to be
married and you're sitting very kind of
now I can poop wherever however yeah
honestly my girlfriend gets really mad
at me cuz like some girls have problems
with like getting a get in and out but I
I do whatever and never I'll go like
four times it's a head okay do you think
like candy crush in this house do you
think the toilet people will team up
with a crockpot people and maybe go into
business all right I've had just about
enough of this topic